welcoming to the rich eisen show uh the
man who
brings you the nateland podcast or is it
nate land we put the
we put that i think it's the land
podcast available wherever you get your
podcast with video
and nate's youtube channel the comedian
nate bergatzi how are you nate
i'm good man how are you guys i just
that was pretty fun to hear about the
seinfeld
i'm a big seinfeld fan so it's pretty
crazy what's your favorite seinfeld
episode nate
i'm a bit uh andrea doria um i think
it's
it's got it it's the one where uh the
guy that's
trying to get the apartment from george
and he is
you know and then george sanders says i
mean how many people die on a regular
cruise 30 40 i mean that's my that
you're talking again the episode where
george is trying to get an apartment
speaking to the co-op board
and he goes story for story with the
other guy who's competing for it an
older gentleman
uh to try and come up with the uh worst
possible story
to win over the board and this gentleman
said andrea doria
and then he goes on this long jag of
talking about everything from his
fiancee
dying by licking envelopes and it was
truly fantastic
that was fantastic that is a brilliant
brilliant episode
yeah when he walks up to that old man
and he goes ahoy maybe
[Laughter]
yeah i guess if i had to choose my
favorite george moment
it was him him going back to the state
of ohio
to tell a joke because he forgot to tell
the best
possible joke like we all have those
moments like we wish we could go back
and and top our moment that we just
totally love that nate you ever have a
moment like that in your life your
career i mean every after every show
i wish i could go right back up there
and do it again
so you're from old hickory tennessee is
that
is that uh that's the is that your
hometown nate that is my hometown
we moved back we're in uh nashville bri
another part of brentwood my family's
all still an old entry it's a suburb of
nashville
okay so it's not as like we're not in
the middle of
you know just one street light or
something where
chris what's the name of the place we
did um karaoke uh santa's pub
where's santa's pub in relation to that
nate yes uh
maybe 15 miles uh kind of
north east okay that's where
santa claus it was yeah that's we lit
that up for the draft
we did it two years ago they're still
talking about it there
well we were they did talk about that
the draft was we were super excited
about i mean that was uh
we're very i'm very proud of nashville
the fact that how good they've done it
it was a it was amazing nate uh i would
go back there
in a heartbeat um if i've said it before
and i'll say it again and i i don't just
say it to people from
nashville it was so amazing that if they
have
a rotation for the draft
similar to the super bowl they should
put nashville in it and keep going back
there
no doubt yeah i agree i would love it it
was fun i went we went i got to go down
i didn't get to go
i love the draft i think i've told you
before like i love your logo is my
favorite logo in all of sports and you
running
uh thank you but the draft is my it's my
absolutely favorite thing
just pure chaos happens and uh
it is just you never know what's gonna
happen and it's just usually something
pretty chaotic
and uh even you watch it's insane you
watch these kids some of them
the money goes down you're watching them
lose millions of dollars
like it's unreal just the drama of it
not that it's
happy but it's just the drama of it is
insane
well so uh are you a tennessee titans
fan does that make you a titan's fan big
yes big titans fan all right so uh we're
knocking on wood that everybody's happy
and healthy and that they can continue
on the three-and-oh
uh start has been something amazing nate
it's it
yeah it's amazing i mean you know the
titans i'm a big vanderbilt fan too so
i'm a van d and titans fan okay and so
they were both going through some pretty
well you know vanity actually had a
really good game this week against texas
a m we did not win
but was very excited about our
quarterback and uh defense looked great
and uh so they it was kind of on the
upswing but they're in the sec
it's kind of an uphill battle and and
the titans were on a long
kind of nothing and then last year was
amazing and
so this year they seemed yeah like they
just picked up right where they left off
so does that make you a jay cutler guy
nate are you a cutler guy
i am i'll defend cutler just out of i
don't you know he could
break into my car and i would tell you
why that's okay
i just i mean he's a vandy guy i don't
think he did anything wrong
i'll argue that denver did him wrong
okay
for making him leave okay uh so he
you know he had a pro bowl that year and
then they they got and then they
like kind of started didn't know what's
his face came in from the patriots
mcdaniels it was floating the idea that
cutler was no good
well that's all it takes you know for
the bra he just did the pro bowl
so why are you trashing him and then he
left and in chicago i just don't think
it you know
was a it didn't really work out there
but he did nothing wrong at denver
you know are you following his uh his
instagram account nate have you been uh
checking out uh jay cutler's instagram
account i've seen some of it i saw like
the
chicken thing where he was right you're
easily trying to get to the bottom of
that
yeah he's got chickens he's got uh mini
cows right he's got these little mini
cows that i didn't even know existed
that's what that's what jay goats he
just got goats last week that's the
latest
we're on a road trip right now is that
right yeah because that's what we every
friday we have uh we catch up with jay
cutler's instagram on the rich
eisenhower and i just love that y'all
were like y'all know where he's at right
now like this
yeah i know he's going he had barbecue
last night oh is that right that's what
that's what jay's up to um i know no one
knew what he's up to
like this is the most anybody's ever
seen him that is true
instagram so like that's why i feel like
he's so fascinating
because he and i mean he's more likable
than he ever was
in the nfl but
so you were just spent all this time
defending him but you deep down realize
that he's a thoroughly unlikable figure
as an nfl player
i get the idea and then i get what i'm
having to do it's an uphill battle man
i'm a vandy fan
what we do is defend stuff that doesn't
always work out for us
but we're there we're always going to
show up okay
and we're always there all right so the
sec team you hate the most would be
which nate pergotzi
tennessee and kentucky pretty good tie
tennessee obviously is our rival with
kentucky
either but i mean after any game i mean
if we lose and i see
two fans cheer for the other team i'm
like this team is the worst
and i can lose my mind right but
tennessee and kentucky are the
they're they're the two i would like to
lump them together
all right so uh tell me about your pod
man uh congrats on it was launched in
july
uh your your guests um who would you
want as a guest if you could wave along
and say this is my guest on the nate
bergotzi nateline
podcast uh you know i don't know maybe
maybe you rich come in we talk about
nothing like we're so we're big seinfeld
fans we actually have a lot of seinfeld
references okay
we talk about the uh and we broke down
grocery stores
uh just like the future present past of
grocery stores
okay and just like it's kind of like
trying to find something that's not
uh topical political like it's just
nothing you're not coming there
to get smarter okay that's not very how
you say that
you're getting dumber is our goal so
rank the isles in the grocery store nate
what do you got for me
you know you're supposed to not go to
the inside the middle you ever heard
that
just don't go to the middle and it's
healthy and i mean i only go to the
middle
that's the uh that's the only thing i'm
in my head i like the mic
i like to find the milk i like to see
where people put where a grocery store
puts the milk
okay that's a little you know it's like
you get a little personality at the
grocery store
uh and i just wear the ice cream what so
i know so
the middle is like a frozen food
situation that is true like they know
they usually cereals are in the middle
okay yeah
so crackers what does it say about a
supermarket where it places the milk
what does the geography of the milk
actually say about the grocery store i
don't understand that
i don't know it's just always in the
back they never make it easy because
that's the one thing that i think
you people have to always get the most
right it's always like go run and get it
so they make you go through everything
yeah to go get it that's right so you
buy more you just you
buy yeah you know i mean you've done the
shopping cart dance before nate i'm sure
it's you take something and you place it
in your cart and you keep boogieing down
with your cart
so that's what they try to make you do
if they try to always carry a basket
and always get way more than that basket
can i mean it becomes at night you're
carrying like
70 pounds
nate it's tough on the forearm and yeah
that's a tough on the forearm
you got you know you got all sorts of
problems working there all right so
i i think i just proved my bona fides
for the appearing on your podcast that
i'm i'm able to talk about nothing if
you just throw me the topic i'll just
talk about it
yeah that's all it is it's i do it to
other comics we talked about we
put one out today about animals just
like i don't know just facts
but they don't have to be okay so we're
going to do it we're going to do it
i'm more than happy to do it uh in the
meantime we'll we'll check it out on
your youtube channel where all
podcasters solve the one night only
drive-in tour
uh you've got tour dates coming up in
columbus ohio
uh illinois um and also in north
carolina for more dates go to nate
bergotzi.com
i appreciate the time nate you take care
of yourself hey absolutely dude thanks
for having me right back at you twitter
and instagram at nate burgazy
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here